[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales de la tnt voici tout de
suite les titres de l'actualité
dans ce journal nous y ont d'abord à
calais où cela fait un peu moins d'un
mois qu'un prêtre et deux militantes
entamé une grève de la faim pour
protester contre les conditions de vie
des migrants ou et aux tv la chaîne de
la voix du nord s'est rendu sur place où
la colère des associations vous le
verrez le faiblit pas
face à la flambée du prix de l'essence
chacun a sa méthode pour faire des
économies ou le verrai quand un cas
rencontré la chaîne télé 7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest a lui opté pour le
covoiturage e-loue l'expliquent dans ce
gîte et dans un instant et puis dans ce
journal le trail autrement dit comment
courir hors des sentiers battus qui fait
de plus en plus d'émules dans notre pays
et elle elle télé sarthe vous fera
découvrir de nouvelles pistes en
compagnie d'une championne du monde de
la discipline
enfin la fin de cette édition vous
verrez les chevaliers du fiel qui ont
ouvert en exclusivité pour les caméras
de la dépêche nos confrères sur place
leur nouvelle salle de spectacle à
toulouse tout juste rénové
je vous le disais dans les titres voilà
près d'un mois qu'un prêtre philippe de
mester et deux militants associatifs
anaïs vogel et ludovic aubin ont entamé
une grève de la faim à calais ils
demandent la fin des expulsions des
migrants et des saisies d'affaires
pendant l'hiver une grève à laquelle
didier leschi un médiateur du
gouvernement envoyée sur place a tenté
de mettre fin en apportant de nouvelles
propositions qu'il détaille au micro de
caroline fichten de wéo la chaîne de la
voix du nord sur place ce qu'ils
appellent le harcèlement c'est justement
le fait de ne pas prévenir les personnes
en amont de la de l'opération de mise à
l'abri voilà et donc il faut justement
prévenir les personnes c'est pour ça que
tant le dans les propositions il ya
l'idée de mettre en place une maraude
qui préviendra les personnes en amont
c'est à dire 24 heures ou 48 heures
avant qui dira ça va se passer à tel
moment vous aurez trois quarts d'heure
pour prendre vos affaires personnelles y
compris la tente et puis vous serez
orienté
vers des hébergements
voilà les propositions du médiateur du
gouvernement n'ont pas du tout convaincu
les associations
ecoutons-les parle de violation des
droits humains et de harcèlement
policier et tout ce qu'on nous propose
en fait ce ne sont pas des mesures en
fait autant les ce qui est proposé par
le gouvernement ce n'est pas la fin des
expulsions la fin du harcèlement et la
fin du traitement inhumain et dégradant
pendant la trêve hivernale en fait c'est
ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui le médiateur
ne prend pas en compte les demandes
propose d'autres d'autres choses qui par
ailleurs existe pour certaines déjà et
qui sont inefficaces les personnes sont
toujours là elles sont toujours dans une
grande précarité est dans une situation
qui est indigne pour notre pays voilà et
puis tout à fait autre chose en
actualité depuis le 30 octobre a débuté
dans les vosges la marche du réveil ce
sont des marcheurs que l'on voit sur ces
images de daniel rigaud vite c'est de
tirer la leçon de vosges télévision ils
se disent contre le pass sanitaires et
les vaccins utilisés actuellement ils
sont attendus le 14 novembre prochain
sur le mont valérien à paris
voilà dans ce journal nous partons
maintenant pour la martinique où sont
proposés des séances d qui coaching aux
femmes guéri du cancer une méthode qui
permet dit on de reprendre confiance en
soi après une telle épreuve les
explications sur place de diana françois
eudoxie et de karine chat sol pour vient
atv martinique
d'idées reçues cheval sans communication
verbale un exercice complexe d qui
coaching pourtant après quelques essais
infructueux
priscilla et manuela y parviennent ces
deux femmes touchées par le cancer du
sein ressortent plus confiants de cette
expérience avec l'animal au début
j'étais assez un petit peu sous pression
donc ce qui fait que justement
l'animal était aussi un petit peu sous
pression donc comme je me suis un peu
détendus et c'est vrai qu'après 7 passes
et ben on a sept se lâcher prise on a on
se sent détendu et on a même envie de
recommencer quand je suis sorti du box
du moins de la carrière il est passé sur
le fil est venu me rejoindre l'air de
rien
c'est un animal surtout un cheval s'il
ne se sent pas en confiance il va pas
arriver à quelqu'un est la preuve là il
reste super bien
lâcher prise ils l'amélioration de la
confiance en soi font partie des
bienfaits de cet exercice le cheval
ressent la personnalité de son
interlocuteur elle lui permet de se
rendre compte des aspects à améliorer ça
permet de prendre conscience de nous
mêmes de l'impact de notre comporte un
comportement
et ça va leur permettre de d'être un
petit peu plus a certes il faut d'avoir
plus d'écouté ou d'avoir
d'avoir plus ses possibilités ou plus de
facilité de dans la gestion du stress
qu'ils ont ça va leur procurer un mieux
être
ça va les aider à avoir plus de
confiance en elle-même et à finir à
cette bataille qui qui demande beaucoup
de soi-même ce type d'accompagnement est
une première pour les membres des
amazones en martinique une activité ou
bi effets physiques et mentaux durant et
après le parent ou de soins des femmes
le fait de pouvoir faire découvrir cette
activité aux femmes que nous
accompagnons notamment celles touchées
par le cancer du sein est une activité
qui rentre complètement pour une reprise
de confiance en soi quand on sort du
parcours de soins
l'activité par le cheval permet un
accompagnement pour travailler sur les
émotions qui peuvent être parfois enfui
outre le cadre thérapeutique
l'équipe coaching est parfois utilisé
par les entreprises dans l'hexagone en
tant que test de personnalité dans le
cadre de recrutement
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité mais vous l'avez vu dans les
titres de ce journal avec la flambée des
prix de l'essence il faut avoir recours
au système d alors quand certains se
font installer un boîtier bioéthanol sur
leurs véhicules ou limitent leurs
déplacements pour faire des économies et
bien d'autres optent pour le covoiturage
comme quentin que bénédicte 2-1 de télé7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest en
nouvelles aquitaine a suivi pour nous
7h20 quand un parent au travail et
s'apprête à récupérer une passagère sur
son trajet comme 1,5 million de français
il a choisi blabla cardelli pour ses
trajets domicile travail on constate
depuis jules permis c'est que on fait
tous le même trajet mais connaît tous
tout seul en voiture
et avec cette application ça parle c'est
vraiment d'optimiser l'utilisation de la
voiture quotidiennement maintenant je
fais les trajets domicile travail avec
avec des passagers quotidiens ou
différent des nouveaux d'un acquis
qu'ils viennent juste pour pouvoir y en
a qui sont là pour une semaine pour un
mois juste pour les vacances permet de
rencontrer plein de gens bonjour ça va
et toi
ouais j'suis et 40
sur ce trajet partagé fait économiser
une heure de bus à cette passagère un
gain de temps mais surtout une source
d'économie pour quentin en moyenne un
conducteur régulier économise entre 80
et 120 euros par mois grâce au
covoiturage dans la région de
l'aquitaine un typiquement on a + 64% de
trajets effectués en covoiturage
domicile travail et aujourd'hui on a
plus de cent mille membres inscrits dans
la région et on voit très clairement qu'
il ya le changement d'habitudes qui lie
à septembre un moment on remet en
question ses habitudes mais il ya aussi
l'augmentation des prix de l'essence qui
fait que plein de gens qui pensaient que
voiture et se disait je vais m'y mettre
se mettre réellement à covoiturer dans
cette période chaque jour neuf cent
mille français optent pour le
covoiturage le gouvernement espère
atteindre les 3 millions de trajets
quotidiens d'ici 2024
voilà nous restons gironde avec cette
édition locale du magazine le point
consacré à bordeaux avec ce titre un peu
provocateur
vous allez le voir faut-il quitter
bordeaux et bien c'est un dossier
réalisé par valérie pfeffer avec de
nombreux articles sur la rançon du
succès de bordeaux sur l'oxygène avec la
revanche des petites villes sur
l'insécurité aussi qui énerve beaucoup
les bordelais des rixes qui exaspère sur
l'immobilier aussi avec ce marché
bordelais qui s'assagit enfin un ouvrage
magnifique qui reprend le flambeau de
gustave eiffel éditions locales bordeaux
du point puis on reste dans le sud ouest
avec le point toujours qui consacre une
édition à montpellier en occitanie avec
ce titre montpellier révolution dans
l'assiette alors là on reste chez les
épicuriens avec bien sûr l'agriculture
les summer du futur avec un sujet
consommation une interview de nicolas
bricas ce que vous verrez dans cette
édition
dossier réalisé par audrey emery et
valérie préfère toujours avec le
volontarisme en vogue à montpellier un
entretien avec le maire michel de la
fosse enfin à la carte ce que vaut
vraiment le nouveau jardin des sens à
montpellier voilà l'édition locale du
point spécial montpellier
voilà et puis bientôt dans l'actualité
noël car dans un peu plus d'un mois le
père noël lui même viendra distribuer
aux enfants sages ces joujoux par
milliers enfin par milliers ce n'est pas
certain les professionnels du secteur
craignent crise sanitaire oblige une
pénurie de jouer alors le plus célèbre
des barbus aura t'il quelque chose dans
sa hotte réponse dans ce reportage à
tous signé les aurais bérol pour vioxx
itani
playmobil lego peluches ou bien encore
figurines ces jouets se retrouvent
souvent au pied du sapin à noël mais
cette année une pénurie pourrait bien
vous empêcher de les acheter alors
certains préparent déjà l'achat de leurs
cadeaux qu'ils aient commencé il ya un
mois déjà
on est allé les les frais comment ce
taux est comme ça aussi je ne suis pas
au dernier moment dans les magasins l'un
des deux mondes on s'y prend un petit
peu à l'avancé pour éviter de de faire
ça dans les embouteillages on s'est fait
avoir l'année dernière donc justement là
on essaie de s'y prendre maintenant
pendant qu'ils encore du choix la
crainte d'une pénurie liée au manque
d'approvisionnement des matières
premières et de composants électroniques
plane au dessus des distributeurs et des
marques la faute en partie à la baisse
de la production dans les usines et au
transport maritime international
tous deux perturbé par la crise
sanitaire dans cette enseigne à toulouse
on l'a sur il n'y aura pas de problèmes
de stocks l'entreprise a anticipé et
aujourd'hui à commander des quantités
nécessaires pour que nous puissions
avoir un noël
dans toute tranquillité aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de crainte en tout cas de
pénurie sur la partie de jeu on commence
à voir nos clients qui arrivent
effectivement parce que déjà ils
craignent
une pénurie mais aussi pour organiser
anticiper les choses mieux vaut être
prudent et ne pas trop tarder pour
acheter ses cadeaux
voilà toujours dans l'actualité nous
partons pour la loire-atlantique savez
vous ce que deviennent les vêtements et
les chaussures que vous avez déposé si
vous habitez la région dans l'un des
22000 conteneurs du relais la société
coopérative récolte pas moins de 150
mille tonnes par an de textile alors
comment sont-ils triés et recyclés pour
le savoir anne ludique de télénantes
s'est rendu dans un des entrepôts situés
à couëron regardez tout commence dans
ses veines on en compte un millier dans
le département aussi souvent que
possible les chauffeurs du relais
viennent les vider les sacs sont
emportés ensuite direction coup et rond
c'est ici que la marchandise est
acheminé tous nos camions de collecte de
rentrer dans cette partie de notre
entrepôt et puis viennent décharger
leurs textile dans des bacs des grands
bacs bleus qui alimentent notre centre
de tri et l'excédent de collecte qui va
partir dans les grosses case gris ce
qu'on va derrière moi ce matin-là 17
tonnes prendront la direction de la
somme la loire atlantique collecte plus
de vêtements qu'elle ne peut en trier
alors l anrt dispatch sur le territoire
français il faut dire qu'il y a déjà
beaucoup à faire ici pour les 18
salariés là on à l'atelier chaussures
dans les sacs de chaussures on va
trouver de tout on trouve des chaussures
on trouve des peluches il ya des sacs à
main et l'ensemble va être triés tous et
en bon état va être omis dans nos
boutiques ding fring ou vie en ré emploi
et puis après on a un peu on a un peu de
déchet de chaussures mais les 17
chaussures vont partir pour fabriquer un
ce qu'on appelle un combustibles solides
de récupération
donc même les déchets sont recyclés le
plus gros du travail c'est surtout avec
le textile les sacs qui ont été
collectés sont mis en bacs pour aller
monter la scène de tri est ici on a
trois ce qu'on appelle 3 cracker qui
ouvre les sacs et qui du coup vont
envoyer sur le centre de tri tous les
vêtements qui doivent arriver et qui
vont être classés en catégorie le tri ce
sont ces femmes qu'il effectue alors le
critère d'un vêtement qui va partir dans
nos friperie ding fring il faut que le
vêtement soit vos propres en bon état
sur les relais en afrique on n'en voit
que des vêtements qui sont légers
puisqu'on est sur des pays chauds et
puis si jamais c'est un vêtement un
pull-over qu'est bouloché et ces
personnes de toute façon on ne
l'achètera ait lieu à partir en
recyclage
puisqu'on va récupérer la fibre il va et
effilochées il va refaire un fil pour
refabriquer un vêtement ou ce qui se
fait vingt ans que l'inde achète de la
deux
de la matière première autant pour
fabriquer les tapis donc on a plein de
destinations différentes et enfin on a
tous les vêtements en coton qui sont
usés qui vont être coupés en chiffons
d'essuyage parce qu'ils sont utilisés
par des industriels 40% de la
marchandise partira en afrique des
palettes compact et sont acheminés par
cargo elles mettront un mois pour
arriver à destination
voilà et puis dans ce journal
connaissez-vous l'agriculteur 2.0 et
bien à dieu pour lui les fourches les
bêches les trayons manon touati 2,8 mon
blanc l'a rencontrée cet éleveur qui a
automatisé une partie de son
exploitation et qui n'y trouve que des
avantages
regardez ce sujet
ramassez le disait rapprocher le foie
frais et traire les vaches ce sont des
tâches répétitives et énergie 20 pour un
agriculteur depuis 2005 françois chameau
à un robot pour la traite à l'époque
c'était une révolution mais aujourd'hui
la quasi-totalité des éleveurs on
utilise et depuis deux ans françois
cette équipe et d'autres machines qui
lui permettent de mieux gérer son temps
ça permet non seulement bas de de gagner
en souplesse de travail mais aussi en
efficacité parce que en fait c'est des
tâches repousser la bouffe ou oracle et
du lisier ses balles et dash les plus
intéressantes du boulot et les robots
eux non seulement de traire tout le
temps et de nous enlever l'astreinte sur
12 h 30 horaire de la traite et nous
facilite aussi la détection
d'éventuelles maladies et c'est un outil
d'aidé à la décision c'est grâce à un
collier à capteur que la machine est
capable de suivre le rythme de vie des
vaches une méthode efficace pour
détecter rapidement les problèmes de
santé des animaux le lait est analysé
pendant la traite de la machine qui voit
rapidement s'il ya un problème c'est un
gain de temps énorme qui permet de
cibler des actions à mener avec une
vache en particulier
un gros paquet de données dessus donc
derrière à nous de le boulot de notre
boulot d'éleveurs maintenant c'est
d'exploiter les données et en fait ça
nous donne des symptômes et à nous de
mettre le nom sur la maladie derrière et
de la soigner mais c'est vrai qu'on est
vachement plus précoce sur la détection
des maladies qu'elle soit du goût
métaboliques ou ou par exemple un
problème de mamelles ou de ou de fièvre
de voilà et du coup on n'intervient plus
rapidement et du coup avec des médecines
plus douce avec 108 vaches sur
d'exploitation impossible de surveiller
qui a déjà mangé et pouvoir nourrir
celles qui ne se sont pas fait une place
pour le repas une installation lui
permet de donner du foin en deux fois et
à plusieurs reprises dans la journée et
la nuit pour qu'elles aient tout
l'occasion de manger en quantité dans un
troupeau il ya les dominants et les
dominés les plus les plus cons le
tempérament un peu plus agressif elles
vont venir manger d'abord et les petites
derrière quand le petit robot va
repasser les gros sont rangés seront
partis faire autre chose et les petites
ont à leur disposition du coup du
fourrage fait ça permet que tout le
monde mange frais et mots quand elle
mange à fourrage frais et de qualité moi
ça aurait dû l'être pays paie du lait de
qualité de meilleur rendement françois
chabot a vu ses marges augmenter
d'environ 5% grâce à l'aide de ses
robots aujourd'hui trois autres éleveurs
du secteur sont équipés des mêmes
machines preuve que l'agriculture 2.0
s'est démocratisée voilà il ya une
vingtaine d'années le trait il faisait
son apparition en france le trail ce
sont des courses hors des sentiers
balisés et il faut dire que cela a de
plus en plus la cote en france on
dénombre aujourd'hui plus de 900 mille
adeptes ainsi c'est tout naturellement
que la sarthe a décidé de se doter de
pistes qui vous allez voir ont été
validés par une championne en la matière
reportage d'anthony python à challes
pour alerter les sartre sur place
faire du trail toute l'année sur des
sentiers entretenus et balisés c'est
désormais possible
en sarthe les deux premiers itinéraire
permanent ouvert une boucle de 20 km et
une boucle de 40 km au départ de challes
deux itinéraires qui sont déjà au
quotidien les terrains d'entraînement de
nathalie mauclair y avait tout où les
ingrédients d'un trailer peut attendre
d'un parcours de trail des pistes
essentiellement que de la piste à 90 95
% donc pas de bitume
du chemin des racines des cailloux du
pré du sable qui en fait un terrain très
variés des paysages un peu différent
plus largement différents secteurs en
sarthe vont devenir des points de départ
de chemin de trails les tracés sont en
cours d'élaboration
ils seront regroupés sous le label
station de trails et classés par couleur
comme des pistes de ski et à saint
léonard des bois et à la ferté bernard
il y aura à sillé le guillaume il y aura
la flèche pour l'instant on est à cinq
civils civils qui vont être qu'on sera
obligé de faire moi et mon chef et toute
l'équipe technique de manière à refaire
le balisage et puis allez aussi d'abord
trouver des parcours au pire voir un peu
ce qui va ce qui va pas au delà de
l'aspect sportif la mise en place de ces
chemins de trail poursuit aussi un
objectif d'attractivité et de
développement touristique pour
centraliser toutes les informations
relatives aux chemins de course à pied
en sarthe une base de trails a ouvert à
champagnier elle est gérée par
l'association animation tourisme
voilà puisque vous regardez ce journal
autour ou peut être pendant un repas et
bien emmanuel macron a brandi lorsqu'il
était de passage dans la loire le 25
octobre dernier un fromage qui s'appelle
la fourme de montbrison
on a également pu voir ce fromage dans
les émissions top chef récemment une
publicité dont se réjouit le président
du syndicat de la fonte de montbrison
hubert du bien au micro de céline
ersilia de tl7 la télévision de la loire
on a pu le constater les autres années
beaucoup de gens se connectent à notre
site beaucoup de gens reviennent voir
des recettes et du coup
c'est intéressant pour nous ça nous fait
connaître par des consommateurs qui ne
connaissaient pas auparavant donc oui
c'est intéressant a effectivement le
président de la république a porté à
fond de montbrison en trophée à cette
semaine à montbrison et c'est tant mieux
pour nous c'était pas prévu comme ça
mais ça s'est passé comme ça c'était
très bien
voilà et puis pour les amateurs
de fromage en général d'ailleurs sachez
que du 27 février au 2 mars se tiendra à
paris le salon du fromage
et puis on continue avec les bons
produits de nos régions après la fourme
de montbrison une toute nouvelle bière à
consommer bien évidemment avec
modération vient de faire son apparition
dans le vexin à théméricourt se sont
jérôme errants et elisa un état de vie à
95 qui nous le font découvrir écoutons
c'est elle la nouvelle création de la
ferme brasserie du vexin hi pay pour
india pale ale une bière créé au xviiie
siècle par les anglais pour qu'elle
résiste au voyage jusqu'aux colonise
indienne plus houblonnée et donc plus
amer pas vraiment du goût de denis
sarget au départ habitué à produire des
bières douce il s'est finalement laissé
convaincre par la version de son fils or
aignan teinté d'un léger vous de
pamplemousse on mettait pas trop en
avant les goûts de houblon si vous
voulez comme on est céréalier au départ
on transforme georges de notre
exploitation de cambiaire et donc
l'on s'était pas la priorité il ya une
demande dans la clientèle qui s'est
faite
naturellement puisque bond les gens me
demandaient pourquoi vous ne faites pas
dit pea et notre fils a décidé d'en
faire
c'est la nouvelle génération et il faut
que ça
ça perdure basée à théméricourt la
famille sac je ré et ses deux employés
produisent environ trois mille
hectolitres par an avec désormais dix
sortes de bières tondeuse saisonnière au
printemps et à noël sans compter sa
propre limonade et son colle à
l'histoire de cette brasserie familiale
commence il y a vingt ans notre fils
voulait revenir sur l'exploitation
agricole les revenus agricoles ont chuté
énormément il ya des années où on sur
l'exploitation n'est plus en négatif
donc pas l'air faire autre chose à la
avec et puis transformer un produit de
l'exploitation et puis être différent de
tout ce qui se faisait déjà auparavant
donc à 20 ans il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de microbrasseries aujourd'hui ça
fleurit dans tous les coins mai
et à 20 ans
on était dans des pionniers pratiquement
un pari gagnant pour les producteurs qui
ont su s'imposer sur le marché de la
bière artisanale près de 200 visiteurs
viennent se ravitailler chaque week end
et la brasserie faune et même de temps à
autres l'elysée en succès couronné par
une cinquantaine de décoration depuis le
temps qu'on a fait des concours et qu'on
on gagne des prix eux
ça conforte dans la qualité de nos
bières c'est une satisfaction et puis
moi je suis né pour faire de la
compétition dont j'adore ça mais
voilà une guerre comme l'avait dit au
casse c'est un franc succès quoi c'est
une bière qui passe de partout une fois
n'est pas coutume lie pineuilh du vexin
s'est vu décerner sa première médaille
de bronze cet été
voilà on a vu rapidement des images tout
à l'heure dans les titres ils sont
humoristes ils sont toulousains et ils
sont les nouveaux et heureux
propriétaire du rex une salle de
spectacle située en plein coeur de la
ville rose ils s'appellent les
chevaliers du fiel et après 22 mois de
fermeture 700000 euros de travaux le
célèbre duo a enfin ouvert ce lieu cher
à leur coeur comme il l'a confié à manon
aussi du groupe la dépêche du midi
écoutez on pourrait l'appeler au rex
parce qu'on a toujours fait notamment
niveau du look mais surtout au niveau de
l'insonorisation la lumière tous les
murs sont soulevés pour éviter les
vibrations ça a été long fastidieux et
cher voilà tout ça vaut rester bons amis
avec nous comme ça on peut faire un lieu
de musique très branché très jeune en
place entre rex à l'origine c'était un
cinéma et mes deux salles et nous on y
est allé un peu plus d'une fois c'était
notre cinéma de quartier j'avais orange
mécanique
sorti un ciné-club quoi après et puis
ensuite donc se transformer nous il faut
savoir qu'à l'origine on est toulousain
koné musiciens on a été étudiant à
toulouse donc la vie étudiante à
toulouse quelque chose qui nous qui nous
parle et on aime on aime bien perpétrer
un peu cette tradition de sorties de
fêtes toulousaines du hip hop à l'humour
en passant de la comédie en revenant par
le dj tout ça c'est une forme de culture
voilà et puis regardez ces images de la
chanteuse catherine lara décoré des
insignes de commandeur dans l'ordre
national du mérite s'il vous plaît par
l'ancien premier ministre bernard
cazeneuve un événement qui a eu lieu à
poissy ville de naissance de la
chanteuse et qui a été immortalisée par
les caméras de nos confrères de tv 78
alors félicitations à catherine lara
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales de
la tnt et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve
très vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]